bientôt le grand rush et les milliers de
passagers éparpillés dans l'aéroport
ceux qui partent ce qui arrive ce qui
transite et là où ça bloque le plus
c'est au niveau des départs
enregistrement filtre douaniers alors un
seul mot d'ordre pour les compagnies
aériennes et les autorités
aéroportuaires anticiper les compagnies
aériennes en modifier l'heure limite
d'enregistrement qui passait de 1h à
1h30 ce qui fait qu'ils voient donc avec
les anciennes habitudes on risque
d'avoir des congestions et donc
notamment à l'enregistrement et au
passage des filtres police et de sûreté
donc la roque recommandations la forte
que nous faisons c'est venez enregistré
le plus tôt possible 2h 3h avant la
plupart des compagnies aériennes pour
permettre l'enregistrement la veille 2
lors de leur voyage
et ça effectivement ça facilite beaucoup
la vie de nos clients
le jour de leur départ les autres
recommandations au niveau des bagages
une vérification est toujours nécessaire
surtout avec les nouveautés proposées
cette année une particularité c'est la
mise en place pour les compagnies depuis
plusieurs semaines et mois de tarifs
sans bagage donc il est très important
que les clients vérifie si le billet
qu'ils ont acheté inclut pas un bagage
de soute des agents reconnaissable
seront aussi déployés à tous les niveaux
pour aider les voyageurs en période de
pointe
on peut compter jusqu'à neuf mille
passagers par jour qui fréquentent
l'aéroport